[موسيقى] أجنبية
لدينا هنا مناطق محددة
بوضوح لاستخدامات مختلفة ، فنحن
نقف حاليًا على قمة الطريق الروماني
الذي اكتشفنا أنه يمر عبر
المنطقة بأكملها وهذا القسم هنا
بعرض 10 أمتار والطريق
لا تتجاوز معظم الطرق الرومانية الاتساع أكثر
من حوالي أربعة أمتار في
الوقت الذي تكون فيه عربات
قادمة والسيارات تنزل إلى الطريق الويلزية
للوصول إلى الطريق الروماني هناك
إلى الشرق يجلب الناس المنتجات  في
الحيوانات والسلع التجارية الأخرى هي أن تكون
منطقة نشطة للغاية
[موسيقى
] المنطقة على يميني من المحتمل أن تكون
منطقة استيطان محلي للحيوانات
نزولاً نحو الجنوب الشرقي ، لدينا
منطقة حصلت على كل دليل على الأفران
وصنع الخبز بشكل أساسي و  ثم
خلفي مباشرة هو أكثر من تسوية محلية ،
لذا ما ستراه هو
نشاط كبير جدًا يقوم به الأشخاص الذين يقومون
بأشياء مختلفة يعيش فيها
أشخاص يعملون ويتاجرون أيضًا
[موسيقى]
أنت